hey guys what's up as we get deeper and
deeper into the adoption globally of
bitcoin i figured i'd tell you a couple
of stories people may never heard before
so here's one for you in 2018 bitcoin
was at 20 000
or so at the start of the year it then
proceeded to drop all the way down to
about three thousand dollars by the end
of the year what a lot of people don't
know is that year myself mark gusco
jason williams all three of us we
actually were able to get a meeting with
one of the sovereign wealth of the
largest funds in the entire world these
people got hundreds of billions of
dollars and so we sat down with them
we've repaired a 20-plus page white
paper on bitcoin we explained what it
was how it worked what the risks were
what the potential pros to it were what
they could do from an asset allocation
standpoint how the past price history
had worked every single thing you could
possibly want to know about bitcoin at
that time we put into that paper some of
the people from their team came in we
went ahead we met with them we presented
the entire thing we talked through all
the nuances of it at the very end of the
meeting they asked us what exactly
should we do
our ask to them was give us at the time
about a billion dollars we're going to
go ahead and we're going to buy 210 000
bitcoin a percentage of the network and
we're going to give that to the
sovereign wealth claim you're going to
hold on to it you're never going to sell
it you're going to become one of the
richest nations in the entire world now
of course hindsight buys being 2020.
that'd been a pretty good idea bitcoin
was less than 5 000 at the time and for
about a billion dollars they would have
done pretty damn well now of course they
didn't do it and so ultimately they're
still interested they're still looking
around they're still trying to figure
out what they should do in the bitcoin
cryptocurrency industry but that's the
type of stuff that goes on behind closed
doors people with big dollars have been
paying attention to this asset class for
a long time now that sovereign world
fund didn't actually get into the game
but we've seen many many other sovereign
wealth funds go ahead and actually start
to allocate capital to this industry
some of them have decided to go ahead
and buy the assets themselves other ones
have backed individual companies in the
industry and even others have gone ahead
and actually invested with asset
managers or investors and so we're going
to give you money and you go ahead and
you get us the exposure however they're
going to do it all of them are going to
eventually jump in the game and so we go
all the way back to 2018 at the bottom
of the bear market and we asked that one
single sovereign wealth fund for about a
billion dollars they didn't do it but it
would have been a pretty good idea so
i'm really excited to see a lot of these
folks start to now get comfortable we've
got tons and tons of financial
institutions on wall street lots of
well-respected best investors in the
world all allocating
capital to the industry and so now it
provides career risk cover there is no
career risk if it all goes to zero
tomorrow you can point and say well the
best in the world did it so of course i
did it as well that my friends is the
ultimate opportunity we've got
individuals in the game we've got
corporations got a lot of wall street
institutions but the sovereign wealth
funds we need them they're coming and i
can't wait to see what they do when they
decide to start pouring billions tens of
billions in some cases hundreds of
billions of dollars over the coming
decade or two into this industry it's
gonna be absolute fireworks so pay
attention sovereign wealth funds they
definitely been snooping around for a
while but when they start to allocate
they're gonna come hot and heavy